love isn't personal that's the main
point and that's what we keep forgetting
that's its main delusion
its main hysteria because it isn't yours
it isn't mine
it probably doesn't even belong to the
gods eros was not himself a god the
notion of love is strange very foreign
to the character of a God in the Greek
context in the context of most cultures
except christianism that's supposed to
be Christianity's virtue its uniqueness
Christianity made love into its God
Christianity made love into its God so
to stay in touch with our cultures God
we have to feel loved be in love be
loveable love others and ourselves as a
commandment and then love becomes a huge
problem the main effort of therapy so
you see how the point there is that that
again the judeo-christian background
effects even the way we regard what's
really terribly important in our lives
the love problem in the Christian
culture is all wrapped up with saving
ourselves and finding God even this
conversation now that we are talking so
much about love has us right in the trap
of our Christian culture if we could
only let love alone if we could only
give it more space and less attention it
would take care of itself it's like
having a friend in the house don't
badger him making [ __ ] making him
comfortable or a patient don't keep
taking his temperature if we could just
get out of the way let it come let it go
we are always trying to direct love into
channels relating it sharing it doing it
right why so the other person says we
are afraid of it it's ready to break out
any minute and what at once is psyche
it's after soul it has a job to do on
the soul I mean love is far more
interested in our fantasies in our
images and
complexes than it is in us personally
what we feel and need and long for now
that's a curious idea because we keep
feeling that our love is not you know
the love situation you're in is not
taking care of your needs and your
feelings and your complexes you're not
doing enough for me you're not this for
me you're not you're not meeting me
you're not all of those things that we
want love is not taken care of but maybe
the law love is taking care of something
why are you why do you still stay hooked
to that person maybe the love is doing
something to your fantasy life to your
complexes keeping you hooked it's taken
it's doing something to your psyche but
it's not taking care of your needs so
that would suggest that love is really
more interested in the psyche than it is
in the in the so called ego or or what
you think are your feelings or whatever
so there's dissatisfaction in your
feelings at the same time you're hooked
on a situation which is impossible it's
not doing what you wanted to do and what
it should be doing and all the rest a
curious thing very curious thing and
what we what we fall in love with is
usually another person's fantasy world
but not necessarily law rather than two
people but two people don't even know
who the hell they really are and nobody
knows who anybody is but they're like
two fantasies that fall in love like two
cartoon characters
so we are deathly afraid it starts all
the complexes jumping
it makes our fantasies irresistible
Guild's them golden Aphrodite they
called her glowing burning but love
isn't some independent force outside the
images outside the complexes it's right
inside them I mean this is very obscure
for me but I think we try to understand
what it is the eros is already right
there inside the psyche ready to break
into fire it's experience at any moment
you can catch fire at any moment you can
catch fire the French call it the coup
de food no a lightning flash so at any
moment it's potentially there and your
psyche can be caught the psyche is a
highly flammable material so we are
always wrapping things in asbestos
keeping our images and fantasies at
arm's length because they are so full of
love I mean that that's a much for me
that's a much nicer way of thinking
about it then thinking about you got all
this psychic material and then love
comes in as a independent factor but
suppose there's the potential of being
caught and burned all the time in the
psyche and so you're always trying to
keep keep yourself under control or
under wraps so that you don't go up in
flames you're always in love and the
thing you do is to keep that wrapped and
Rumi's a wonderful poem because he takes
the wraps off it
admits that the psyche is in a sense
constantly infla in the flame of of
being in desire or being so partly the
need for another person is so that you
can take the wraps off but if you take
the wraps off possibly then the other
person isn't quite as crucial that was a
fastball I don't know I can say it again
yeah the other the other person you
think the other person is crucial
because of your keeping it in wraps
you're keeping the fact that you are in
love under wraps
in asbestos and so you want the other
person to ignite it or recognize it or
so on but if you take the wraps off and
Rumi sense that you sense the fact that
you are in love and have been in love
since you were 9 like Dante and Beatrice
and are always in love and that your
fantasies are I mean that your psychic
material is is rich with I don't know
how else to say just being in love but
combustible then the other person isn't
quite as crucial
because is it the other person or is it
the fact that you're ignited that is
obsessing you and what to do with the
fact that you're ignited see Freud was
right the content of the repressed
psyche is eros and resistance has to do
with fire resistant walls naturally
everyone backs off from analysis from
their dreams and their figures they are
packed with love but the way into loving
isn't direct you can't go straight at it
and therapies that encourage love that
focus on transference make that mistake
of going straight at it at least for me
the way is via the soul the images where
love is hiding anyway just start talking
with anyone from the soul about the soul
about your fear of dying about a
heartbreaking memory about your funny
estrangement isolation and right away
love starts happening I just read that
again just start talking with anyone
from the soul about the soul about your
fear of dying about a heartbreaking
memory about your funny estrangement
isolation and right away love starts
happening see it just big it breaks out
it begins to happen when when when the
level of the talk is from there
naturally it breaks out in therapy
sessions wherever there is psyche there
is amor eros love love comes into
therapy defined psyche to become
psychological and it really is a
psychological mistake to take love
personally of course it feels personal
because love is interior intimate but
this in earnest refers to the soul and
the activation of the complexes see
that's a hard one because when we feel
something is intimate and in
here we feel it's personal and it isn't
necessarily personal everybody feels
exactly the same way it's a completely
collective event The Alchemist said that
as you go on with the work
soul work soul making its love will
increase in you
they didn't say you will love more or
better they didn't say the work will
love you more that you will find love
beloved I think they were referring to
the strange factor that is you become
occupied with a psyche there is this
increase the soul grows with a vegetable
love a mineral love and of course an
animal love which we are closer to and
recognize more but this increase is not
an increase of consciousness it's not an
increase like maturation and development
the growth fantasy underneath these
humanistic secular ideas there is an
alchemical activity going on in the
plant kingdom and the mineral kingdom as
if the leaves on the trees just come out
in the spring because they love - as if
rubies and emeralds grow in the rocks
like drops of intense love as if the
rocks themselves are full of desire
reaching towards some crystalline
intensity some luminosity inside
themselves
now all this takes heat terrible
pressure inside the tree branch
inside the ore so we fall in love and
blush red and get hot pants that's the
alchemical love increasing in you very
concrete very physical because it's
inside nature itself see it's another
way of looking at why the trees throw
out their leaves that they that it's
it's the it's not just the SAP rising in
a biological sense because of no it's
March and the SAP rises in the maple
trees when cold nights and warm days
doubt it but suppose we imagined it
through the idea that the
love the trees love to do that or that
instead of imagining a chameleon or a
lizard or a crab changing its color when
it moves into a new environment and we
call that camouflage because predators
would get it if it didn't do that kind
of Wall Street fantasy that you've got
to cover up all the time or the
Predators get you and camouflage theory
of of animal life that an animal dresses
that way in order to be liked because it
likes to do that likes to change its
coat in order to get on with its
neighbors instead of imagining always in
terms of what you get with the TV about
animals I mean little crabs for example
there are species of crabs when they
have them in one aquarium with green
plants and green moss and green stuff
the crab is takes all this green stuff
and and hides in it and makes itself
green dresses green and they take that
same crowd and put it in another
aquarium with a lot of red sea anemones
and coral and this and that and the crab
takes off all this stuff and it has on
all the sea moss and it puts on red and
dresses itself all over again now if you
read it through the paranoid fantasy the
crab is protecting itself from predators
through camouflage but you can also
imagine that the crab wants to be
adapted and live in a nice in an
environment with everything else that it
that what motivates a lot of activity is
love not fear necessarily not
necessarily and then it would it would
feel different about the way things are
you know the symbiosis that goes on
between insects and plants and the way
one lives in the world that one lives in
the world because you can just as well
say fear permeates all things as the
Buddha said
therefore fear not or you can say love
permeates all things and so we are
always in love